are modern women children and what
inspired this is I used to watch a lot
of like pickup videos
um
like
um what's that guy's name alpha male
strategies I used to do reactions to him
I used to do just like guys in the
pickup and like relationship sort of
game and one
thing that a lot of either dating
coaches or pickup coaches said was to
treat women like children
because they're so emotional that you
have to like act like they're children
and I wanted to know men's point of view
have you heard that before
um
I've never heard that before
but I think it look it happens in a lot
of that in application so in terms of if
you were to break to a lady that she's
she's got a fat you'd have to break it
in bite side terms you wouldn't be able
to tell her the realness so you'd have
to assume like a child how the child
reacts if you were to tell them
something of that magnitude but really
if you just say to your boy like when I
gained weight my boy just laughed at me
he said grab my belly and said that what
happened
so you almost have to cuddle women a
little bit yeah you have to be talking
like you know when you're it's obviously
you're a different system but the
English people like GCSE Buffalo is like
I'm not saying that but if you know just
slightly if you just you know and you
just have to turn it around and just
talk with my knees woman is yeah
me as well I've never heard of that term
but
in life you you kind of notice these
kind of things because obviously girls
want to get looked after and you know
they're emotional and stuff like that
and as you said you have to kind of like
give them the truth in bite size so
because obviously they can't really
handle the whole truth leading on that
but what you're saying about being
looked after
a lot of modern women compared to Old
School women they're actually looking
for a father so they're looking to be
treated like a princess then rather than
being treated like a queen so in terms
of that's probably what Pick Up Artist
means and a lot of women want sweet
things which is something okay let's say
they'd want you to
come back when they come back from work
for you to wait up for them for crazy
hours that's something your father would
do as your partner your partner you have
other things to be dealing with rather
than to be holding your hand through
every single incidence but that probably
leads back to the emergence of the
single parent home and looking for that
Father Figure what do you guys think
um I I do think that with women we we uh
we have that emotion emotional side
sometimes and sometimes people feel they
might have to tiptoe around things but I
haven't actually heard that myself
actually but overall I do believe um
that women do have those those traits as
well what about you yeah I think we are
emotional as women but the the to
compare us against like talking to us
like children it's like what what is
meant by that like what is meant by
talking to us like children because when
I imagine someone talking to a child
it's almost like you know putting on
this putting on this facade or like
high-pitched voice and excited and being
like no no no you know like hi little
baby AI whereas I think we do wait do
women
since when do like what do we really
need to be communicated I think it's not
that um it's not talking to you as
children like as in putting on a
high-pitched voice but it's more in the
sense of like
when you're talking to a child you have
to kind of you know there's a saying
that I don't know what film it was some
guy will say oh tell me like I'm six
years old so that I can understand so
it's like when you want to talk to it
like when you have to talk to a child
you have to tell them things in a
certain way so that they understand you
won't talk to a child the same way that
you'll talk to a grown adult but with
women like you won't necessarily talk to
them like a kid like a little baby but
you'll talk to them you won't you will
talk to them in a manner where
you're kind of like beating around the
bush just so that they can understand
what you're saying and not and so that
they don't you know take it to one
extreme or another extreme and sometimes
you will Pander to them and change your
voice like you know that just that dress
looks horrible and it looks terrible but
you'll just say ah you know what maybe
it's not the day for this maybe the Sun
the way the lighting is not but it looks
[ __ ] and that's the way you talk to a
child you know what I think of what I
think of like that you have to talk to
women like children if I if I say on a
show I say you know women like men with
money the men don't go around and say
well it's not all all women like men
with money or like like guys don't do
that but if a girl if I say hey men
prefer thin women there's always someone
that's like well but not all men like
thin women and it's almost like talking
like pulling teeth sometimes or even
like trying to have a discussion about
like the abortion debate right someone
always brings up grape
always even though it's less than one
percent of abortions and so it's like I
it's really hard to have conversations
with women without them bringing up the
exception to the rule
yeah that makes right that makes com but
then but again again you're like looking
at things from like all different
perspectives if you're saying that
there's that most women are be you need
to talk to most women like children then
obviously that's still an argument to an
exception not the rule oh no I mean like
most I'd say that's more the rule like
like I talk to women every day you know
and like I'm not saying there's not
reasonable women that you can have
conversations with I meet them all the
time but I'd say like there's a
substantial percentage of women that I I
can't have a conversation with them
without them bringing up some exception
but man like if I bring that up like
they're pretty like they don't argue
with me when I say women like guys with
money or tall guys they're not like
Daily's not here saying like but but you
know even though even though it's very
well even though we understand that not
every single woman might you know love a
man with money some women are content
you know whoever they have we get that
but the overwhelming majority of women
are hypergamous so we have after that
acknowledge that fact and um but when
it's when it's like when you're talking
to a woman as she said when she's
talking about grape or something like
that or when she's talking about
abortion you know women will bring up oh
yeah but there's grape you know and we
understand that there's grapes no one's
arguing that there's there's no grip but
it's that when you bring up those like
those like things that are basically
insignificant in terms of like the 100
of things like it's you know it's kind
of like off putting of the conversation
you're taking things to the extreme kind
of thing do you think that's because
they want to justify the reason or is it
do you think it's a personal aspect
they're coming from It's Always personal
I feel like shows like this and other
shows it's like we talk abstract so for
example when I talk about my pod we talk
about
what ideal male is like so we talk about
the guy has money his respect to much
men women love him good looking etc etc
I'm five foot nine in my message I don't
pick and choose and take height out of
it all because I'm small objectively
that's the truth but then when if you
were to go to like a chubby chaser
podcast where there's loads of big
things they'll start they'll change the
message and say oh you know what some
men like real women and the reality is
if your BMI is a cricket score most men
aren't going to like you
all right
but like so it's almost like you're
coddling girls the same way you coddle
children when you tell them like Santa's
real more like or or like you know when
you you kind of
make some harsh realities softer because
they don't really need to know the truth
it's almost like how women are nowadays
but I find it dangerous I find it
negligent like I find luck do you ever
find that when you chat to your closest
friend you can tell them the real truth
because they're not going to get upset
but it comes from a good place but I
thought even when I look at like my
female friends Dynamics they can't be
entirely honest with each other because
they're mummy cuddling each other which
is a dangerous place to be because
really and truly you should be cut
throat and get to the point in order to
get the best for them do you not think
there's more and more women that are
starting to do that though even with
their friends like starting to become
like more honest more Cutthroat there's
more of like this rise of women who are
looking for that straightforward honesty
as opposed to this
baby talk I think
um I think they they want to but I don't
think they really want to because it's
like it's like you you would say that
yeah the girls want the truth and you
know the hard truth the cold truth and
whatnot but when when they hear the
truth they argue it but do you
understand it's like for example if I
say yeah
um if you say yeah as Pearl said if you
say uh girls like men with money you
know they'll argue it back and won't be
like no no not all girls not all girls
and all you know so it's like they do
want the truth but
they don't they can't they're not really
capable of handling the truth so and I
think a great sorry a great example
would be yesterday's show where we had
three women and we tried to explain to
them that when women get to a certain
age and have kids
their value goes down and they were
adamant that that isn't the case they
could date whoever they want and where
we try to then compartmentalize it to
try and go and beat around the bush so
it wasn't as direct to be like all right
you're not gonna get the guy you want to
commit to you they still couldn't
comprehend what we were saying or
understand what we were saying so but
like if you say to a guy you need to
make more money before you can really
get a girl you're dead broke like who's
gonna date you